[Music]
everybody is Charlie we got surprised
birds of prey footage to breakdown they
dropped a teaser trailer obviously we're
gonna have the Super Bowl next week
pretty safe bet that everybody's gonna
be dropping a lot of teasers and
trailers for other really big movies
this week too so be sure to subscribe to
get everything we'll do new round of
that Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about the teaser on the video so
obviously this is mostly a Harley Quinn
movie but it started out as a Harley
Quinn solo movie then it became more of
a girl gang film Harley Quinn and the
birds of prey so you notice a number of
big Batman villains in that teaser
trailer they're all explained they've
already told us what the plot is but
they have not said whether or not
there's gonna be a cameo from Ben
Affleck's Batman because if there is a
cameo because this is taking place after
Justice League and Suicide Squad it
would probably be Ben Affleck's Batman
if they do recast Batman we probably
wouldn't see that actor till Matt Reeves
film because that's meant to be a
prequel taking place really early in his
career so any of like the Batman related
films that take place in present day are
fair game for Ben Affleck Batman cameo
but the other big thing to start off
with they have also not said what's
going on with Jared Leto's Joker during
this movie too because here I'll read
the official description so it'll make a
little more sense is this after
splitting up with the Joker Harley Quinn
and three other female superheroes Black
Canary Huntress and Renee Montoya come
together to save the life of a little
girl
Cassandra Kane from an evil crime lord
who is Ewan McGregor's black masks so
that's who he's playing if it wasn't
clear the person that blonde Chris
Messina is playing is Victor Zsasz so
he's obviously very bad villain during
the movie we don't know exactly what
he's doing only that he's bad the main
villain is gonna be you and MacGregor's
black mask based on the synopsis what it
seems like they're implying is is that
the movie opens up with the story of how
Harley Quinn leaves the Joker rejects
him it goes out on her own then the
Cassandra Cain plot picks up and all
these vigilantes formed the birds of
prey including Harley
who feels compelled to help out this
little girl who's the daughter of two
very notable Batman comic book villains
she's a very notable member of the
Batman family when she's older but this
is obviously a very young girl version
of the character so none of that stuffs
happened yet her parents in the comics
are Lady Shiva and her father is David
Kane both two of the world's deadliest
assassins in both very notable Batman
comic book villains but because the full
official title of the movie is birds of
prey in the fantabulous Emancipation of
one harley quinn what they might do in
order to make that title make more sense
metaphorically for the actual plot and
all this Cassandra Cain stuff is they
might change her comic book origin and
say that you and McGregor's black mask
is her father with Lady Shiva or another
character because usually when you talk
about emancipation you're talking about
a child emancipating themselves from
their parents before they're of legal
age which is usually around eighteen in
the United States so it's more of a
metaphor for the Harlequin storyline
because she's not married to the Joker
but she's fundamentally tied to him and
it's this really weird codependent
relationship as we've seen it so far in
Suicide Squad but if you're gonna make
that plot apply to the Cassandra Kane in
a more literal sense you'd have to make
one of those villain characters her
father so basically it's those two
female characters Harley Quinn and
Cassandra Cain leaving abusive
relationships it's just that Cassandra
Kane is a little girl and requires a lot
more help I suppose there's a version of
this movie that they could do without
Jared Leto's Joker but it just feels
like you have to have like a small scene
at the beginning of the movie where
Harley Quinn effectively emancipates
herself from him by kicking his ass or
maybe that just happens across the
course of the film and there's some sort
of post-credit scene where she beats the
crap out of him but I'm sure the movie
will invoke him somehow even if he's not
like a really big character during it
remember Jared Leto's Joker is still
sort of like the DC EU version of the
Joker the joaquin phoenix joker movie is
an else world story taking place in a
different continuity will get more
trailers for that soon because it's
coming out later this year the
birds-of-prey movie is being released
next year 2020 in february so it's about
a year away that's why they're dropping
this teaser trailer right now they flash
really quickly through a bunch of
characters and a bunch of Easter eggs so
I'll just do this frame by frame
character by character
so we start with Harley Quinn with her
mallet in her classic costume
then there's Huntress played by mary
elizabeth winstead loves me some black
leather too bad arrows Huntress got way
too famous and busy shooting other
projects to come back to that show the
drunk is Renee Montoya played by Rosie
Perez I'm sure they're not gonna do any
kind of question origin story or
anything like that she'll just be a
regular detective who's seen better days
and gets her [ __ ] together to help this
little kid Cassie Kane and is willing to
work with known criminals like Harley
Quinn and vigilantes like the Huntress
and Black Canary and the birds of prey
to get the job done speaking of the
Gotham City Police Department no word if
JK Simmons Gordon is going to cameo
during the film either there's a way you
could shoot it without including him but
I feel like you'd at least have to
mention him if you're gonna have Renee
Montoya and she's gonna be a detective
even if she's a washed-out detective the
little girl with the pink cast with
obscenities written all over it is
obviously Cassandra Cain
she's got Joker Harley Quinn playing
card symbols there's a Gotham writ large
over the top is Gotham City is mine
there's a crossbow bolts at the top for
Huntress there's a gun for Renee Montoya
the word of magic is written on it maybe
there's a magic based character there's
so many that we haven't seen in the DC
Universe in the movies yet that's
totally possible but they've only
announced a couple of official
characters so if there is a magic based
character then we don't know about her
yet there's a bird for Black Canary
pretty obviously that all the people
that help a rescue Cassie Cain wind up
signing her cast by the end of the film
it would be pretty funny if Ben
Affleck's Batman cameos and he also
signs forecast by drawing a little bat
symbol on it the person in the yellow
costume with the baseball bat with all
the gold seems like Harley Quinn without
her Joker makeup like it seems like
there's lyrics written all over that
baseball bat and it used to belong to
the Joker and she's just taken it from
him maybe that's when she emancipates
herself from him officially the girl
with the microphone is their black
canary played by a journey small at Bell
I assume that means she's playing the
new 52 Dinah Drake version of the
character and when all this stuff picks
up she's either like a lounge singer or
a punk rock singer and a club somewhere
maybe that Harley Quinn goes to and
that's how they connect with each other
this is another Huntress outfit just a
little more tactical the Bertinelli's
are in the film remember the
Bertinelli's are another notable crime
family in Gotham City
Huntress
Jex them and becomes a vigilante so she
has a lot of underworld contacts and a
lot of money to fund all the stuff that
she needs this is Christmas and as
Victor Zsasz they haven't said what he's
doing during the movie if he's a
mid-boss that's tied to black masks or
he's gonna be doing something else and
they just wind up kicking his butt for
some other reason but it'll probably
have something to do with the black mask
plot more Renee Montoya more Black
Canary up close with her microphone more
Ewan McGregor black mask and a different
suit it'll be interesting to see if he
actually gets the comic book black mask
by the end of the movie especially if
the movie is gonna get sequels this is a
better look at Cassie Kane with her cast
the actress who's playing her fun Easter
Egg is actually Dante Bosco's nice so
bangarang to that maybe she'll get her
orphan comic book name during this if
you guys have been watching Young
Justice the orphan Cassie Kane character
is a member of the Batman family working
with Tim Drake's Robin wait where's
orphan
did you know touch was really clay face
just not care it'll be funny to see what
they do with movie kasi cane I expect
her to be super foul-mouthed just based
on all the curse words written all over
her cast there then they closed the
teaser with Harley Quinn getting really
drunk partying in another outfit with a
drink just saying see you soon so I'm
expecting we'll probably get a trailer
by Comic Con later this summer just
because the movie isn't coming out till
February 2020 but let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
this obviously it's gonna be a smaller
film than like your traditional big huge
Batman film but because it's so Batman
adjacent I just expect them to swim in a
lot of Batman Cannon so expect liberal
Easter eggs and any potential cameos
they have not said anything about what's
going on with the Batgirl movie because
she's not supposed to be in this movie
but there might be some sort of brief
tie to that because they're still making
that movie even though Joss Whedon isn't
doing it anymore it's gonna be somebody
else but that's another thing that I'm
expecting to hear about around Comic Con
just because there's all these smaller
DC movies that they're making like
Shazam is meant to be a smaller DC movie
supposedly they only spend about ninety
million dollars making that the big news
about Superbowl trailers that I know so
far is that we're supposed to get an
Avengers end game trailer beyond that I
don't know if there's gonna be new
Captain Marvel trailer or what's gonna
be happening from other people like Game
of Thrones or DC whatever ends up
dropping I will totally make videos for
but feel free to leave all your video
requests in the comments below the black
panther cast was talking about the
sequel to that movie so i'll do a video
for that later tonight click here to
learn about all the secret sinister six
stuff going on during the spider-man far
from home trailer and click here for my
new Shazam trailer Easter Egg video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]